a água muito por aqui é chamada assim e
por estado mas eu não
daniel tem é o que eu pedi pra tu nunca
mais falar essa frase 20 quando eu
voltar para essa casa um brilho ou frase
não falhou
sabella muito bonita
eu tinha tanto o deixa o fato de não
negar você não disse quando eu voltar a
essa casa bem amplo e mais 16 minutos
quando eu voltar eu não vou falar mais
nada
eu costumo em 5 lugar dessa casa
desculpe se eu voltar a achar um
tubman da maneira limpa votada como se
não existisse uma manhã muito e acaba
ficava água mar limpo chegava eco de
casa casa responder limpa e tomar limpa
que tinha no mundo tava parecendo a
igreja chegar uma pessoa que retira o
chinelo que entrou na casa do senhor
chegar a minha mãe casa de neve porque
ela fazer isso aqui está parecendo
pública n coisa
não me espanta vem empurrando a sujeira
que ela roubou do cabelo pelo do diabo
que não sabia o resultado já que o time
da globo
como é que dá uma mulher 10
a união pode contar a história agora que
vai surpreender com a mesma mulher
lá em casa é o seguinte